nearly seven months after the assault on
the capitol washington dc's metropolitan
police say
two more police officers who responded
to the riot
recently died by suicide that raises the
total
of known police suicides to four since
the attack
by supporters of president trump chris
van cleeve is on capitol hill this
morning looking at the impact of those
who defended the capital
on january 6. chris good morning david
good morning it is just heartbreaking
think back one week ago
we were watching as officers battled
back their emotions as they provided
harrowing testimony about their
terrifying experiences
during the attack on the capitol on
january 6th now we're learning the d.c
police department is mourning the loss
of two of their own
an 18-year veteran and a five-year
veteran both
lost to suicide officer gunther hashida
was found dead at his home according to
d.c police on thursday
he was assigned to the emergency
response team and according to his
obituary the father of three
died just shy of his 44th birthday
officer
kyle defrytag was found dead in july d.c
police say he was just
26 years old there are now four known
suicides by officers who responded to
the assault on the capitol
i recently spoke with dc police officer
michael fanon about the impacts of the
insurrection
on him how is it affecting you now there
was a time where i dealt with
some severe and i still experienced like
severe depression
you know almost debilitating like early
on i mean i had like bouts of just like
absolute
like rage i think that was like the
overwhelming
emotion that i experienced like pretty
early on or just like
unbelievable sadness
almost unexplained at the time you know
the justice department has charged more
than 550 people
in relation to the attack on the capitol
on january 6th
and the house select committee is
continuing its investigation
into what happened gail all right thank
you very much chris